hello, how are you, I'm andrés gonzález with
the brief news for april, monday
, march 22, the metropolitan police
is investigating two homicides
that occurred in the early hours of the morning, at the moment
there are not many details of these crimes,
but what is known is that the first one
happened  in sahara near vargas the
second incident occurred on baby and
mere lines near spring spears art
our team attended the scene
and they will bring us more information
changing news starting today
more people are eligible to receive
the coronavirus vaccine  those
over 16 years of age with
pre-existing health conditions will be able to register
for the vaccine in addition, a new
vaccination site opens at the ciecem located
in north las vegas other people
over 16 years of age must wait two
more weeks to receive the vaccine
today also the district
clark county school prepares to
welcome more students into its
classrooms grades 6  9th and 2nd are back under
a hybrid learning model all
remaining grades will return to in-person classes
on April 6 that same day
elementary children are expected to
start full-time in-person school
and now we turn to see the forecast for
weather today we will have a sunny and
warm day hovering around 70 degrees
however in the morning the winds will return
to the valley but it will still continue
with spring weather have a
nice day I am andrés gonzález and that
was about the news now in
spanish
[Music]